hey how's it going guys welcome back to
GameSpot's III coverage
I'm here with Miguel concepción and my
name is NIC margarita and we had the
opportunity to go to the Xbox showcase
and play sea of thieves so Miguel what
was your experience between last year
and this year with sea of thieves
well I naively thought last year that
the game was actually going to be just
based in water and I should have known
that the wood there would be islands and
treasure beyond just like the ship
combat so it was a pleasure to go back
into the game and actually see what
seems like a much fuller experience
where your team just like has these
looks at a map has these targets to
choose from these treasures to go after
and just you know it's this like really
interesting game of teamwork you can
have like totally different experiences
based on like how organized and how
serious right your team is you can kind
of like half half asset but you're not
going to get you know the job done it's
you you would say communication for sea
of thieves is key to your success as a
pirate krill absolutely especially when
you're playing with like other people
online who could be it could be spotting
you from like how many like miles away
and you don't know that they're actually
targeting you right they could be like
hijacking your ship while you're on the
island and that was something that
actually did happen to to me in my
playthrough so a couple of new features
we want to go over there were sharks in
the water this time around so if you're
carrying your treasure back to your
pirate ship did you have any experience
with any sharks coming and attacking no
absolutely the one thing I was happy
about was the fact that I could actually
attack sharks on the beach with my sword
just look I mean there it's easy to lure
them to the beach and you know they were
we were able to make quick
for them Thanks thankfully that we could
actually do sort combat while being like
waist-deep in the water right which is
pretty unique that they have that kind
of kind of threat and it's not just
skeletons on the islands also sharks
going on off that did you experience any
of their new storm weather effects and
features where as you're going with your
ship you might run into some stormy
weather with some choppy seas there was
the risk of that but we were pretty
organized in knowing where our island
was that by the time the storm was
actually going to be a big risk we were
well practically at our target islands
so we didn't that wasn't really that
much of an issue I mean there are more
than of hazards in this game or the more
than a Behrman to consider that we were
happy that we didn't have to really
factor that in and then I guess the last
big new feature they introduced was the
fact that you can fire yourself out of a
cannon did you experience that urge you
fire any of your teammates out of a
cannon um I did see some of my teammates
get fired out of cannon I was so busy
just like being focused upon just gave
the treasure to our ship which we failed
at that I was just more than happy for
my me my teammates you know doing that I
heard you did that had a little
opportunity to fire myself out of a
cannon didn't go so well but you know I
mean despite the that cartoony
presentation and sort of the like I saw
the casual feel of the game I mean I did
like there was certain you can you can
play it as seriously as you like to the
point that you know you are playing like
this traditional treasure hunter where
you are actually using clues to walk X
amount of pieces left
we know forward and you can actually
start digging and the treasure if you
follow the directions is actually there
so there's definitely this tangible
sense of reward
what were your kind of last thoughts
foresee of these is this look like
something you're really excited for in
the coming year
I love how tangible the how rewarding it
is like when assuming that your team is
on the same page and once you actually
like get the treasure they actually work
it's interesting how the work isn't even
done when you get the treasure you
actually have to bring it back to your
ship and that in itself becomes its own
challenge well thank you Miguel for your
insight into sea of thieves which was
shown at the Xbox showcases here and for
all your III 2017 coverage be sure to
subscribe to GameSpot
[Music]